hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Arianna
Basara Arianna ba Suri is ready to film
mr. right hey that's my last name
movies about me the comedy here does not
stop just keeps going non-stop wah
we're gonna watch this trailer stars
Anna Kendrick and Sam Rockwell Kendrick
Anna Kendrick Kendra Andrew yep don't
know what this movie is know nothing
about it but it says it's a funny one
good violence and language good things
are speaking throughout my hey supposed
to be a Milwaukee killing my husband
listen why are you here
bird is wrong Sharon Terry nobody's
perfect
it was like cheating on you
maybe I don't know those things
happening do I just um I just like stuck
ball maybe you're just a
work-in-progress babe how'd you do that
Solana condoms
wow you look great excuse me waiter
okay I want a date and I like this girl
can we do this tomorrow
[Music]
no sorry don't kill somebody in the
parking lot yeah into it why would
anybody kill our guy in public like that
go blow his face off he seems like a
sexy Rain Man or something thank you one
of the world's most notorious
professional tours he quit no Bella
Bella moral code he said he killed a guy
in the pudding ma I thought you used to
still try to hire him but now he kills
him he kills the people who hire him
just unconscious this whole reverse
hitman thing is like weird I know you're
like the greys and then you'll be born
this guy's a supersonic psycho children
I just shoot them in the face some crack
has important with other guns this is
bad
you look handsome Thanks his name for
you mr. right hey stop me that's totally
my life I can kick some ass you did you
said you love it martial arts yeah and I
do have my yellow belt I did Taekwondo
the art of the Korean I think that's how
it goes that looks like a really fun
movie yeah that looks like a really fun
movie yes Anna Kendrick is one of like
the most adorable actresses around right
now people really like her she's tight
Oh tiny is good especially for an
actress right well it's like a lovable
like that what I'm saying like in shake
magazine like bikini front cover Anna
Kendrick I don't think she's done that
she could if she needs to her oh so cute
you know
okay no Anna Kendrick's great and Sam
Rockwell I think he's a fan said oh yeah
he's great unlike anything he does even
in shitty movies he tends to do a good
job joke I'm at the wrong guy no that's
the right woman so Sam Rockwell who I
first saw in the movie Charlie's Angels
has come a long way since then it's cool
to see him playing a badass because
normally he doesn't get the badass role
no like dead BB or like even in Iron Man
2 he's one of the villains but he's more
of like the quirky annoying dumb villain
and it's like come on you know like so
you get an action hero here looks like
he's doing a lot of his own stunts a lot
of the
the fighting and it's cool to see him
like yeah this guy's getting a
commanding lead role and I like the plot
I love it's like you cheated on me numb
badass and I like this killer boyfriend
yeah now I'm killing people I have a
killer boyfriend you know when people
say that yeah that's that's oddly that's
that's a pretty tagline hashtag my
killer boyfriend yeah only see that
going badly no like a hashtag that all
the time
I've killed many men not for her
strictly jealousy so kind of for her
well from her not for her from it seems
to have a quirky offbeat tone that
allows for this world to seem kind of
real of why this what seems like an
ordinary woman because I kind of get a
sense that Anna Kendrick's characters a
little shut down emotionally well it's
the point yeah my boyfriend cheated on
me exactly like getting back her
identity
exactly but she's accepting of this guy
who has this dark career I like that you
know I kind of feel the same way in my
life your dark career like doing
reaction reviews is is like such a dark
journey and Veronica is like you're so
great but then you do these reactions
and it's like who are you in those
moments like I like the moment where
she's where he's dragging the body
across the sea yeah now please I know
this guy and it's the guy who plays with
the boyfriend is cheating on her
why is it bothering you cuz I want to
know if I know it he's clearly not
valuable enough I know him good thing
she's scouting Talent people so keep a
lookout oh you think you actually know
him in real life the max landis I saw
that he wrote this and his name is
pretty popular since around Chronicle
and this guy knows how to write Bond
movies that Inquirer action - I know
Crocker was like the best example of fun
oh that's pretty fun actually
am I talking about
arianna yeah I'm talking you know what
you should do when I talk you should
listen I listen when you talk sometimes
ya know you don't ya and then he's also
did American ultra I know he did that
over that Frankenstein piece of crap but
hey what are you gonna do right every
once in a while you gotta miss American
ultra 50/50 amongst audience so mr.
right mr. right I feel like he got it
right oh good the comedy looks good the
action looks good and most importantly
for a film like this what needs to
matter most is the chemistry between
Anna Kendrick and Sam Rockwell and
truthfully their chemistry looks really
good I feel like they're gonna play off
each other wonderfully so passionate
about this movie wait loriana does know
the guy just watch the trailer gallo Oh
guys you gotta watch this now because
Ariana actually knows and Veronica and I
met someone who is in pitch perfect 2
which stars Anna Kendrick so we're like
we're very involved we uh we are very
like okay well fine Roth Anna Kendrick's
ex-boyfriend in this movie is my real
life friend she also Jewish he's not
he's Italian interesting mm-hmm he
doesn't like being barefoot on stage
it's just a weird facts and Tim Roth is
in this Tim Roth ever since hateful
eight I feel I've been feeling like he's
gonna have a good comeback career now
like he's gonna be back on top soon so
Tim Roth I welcome you into this film
mr. right you are tight when I go to bed
at night I feel a light that makes me
feel so bright I feel I grow and develop
a new height did you know I'm half asian
half white as I fly my kite and I take a
bite out of my sandwich
ripe ripe
that's a boo you know you get called out
that circle if you're new the chimp
subscribe today become a reject
Ariana bah Sri has a channel too
something like that
yeah but she has a facebook fanpage
followed her there oh my god sorry for
fans yeah so is more van depressing
because I made it myself
yeah a few thousand whatever she has a
Twitter yeah mr. Graham let's do a shout
out real fast before this video is over
no no I want to give a shout out to
Ariana's mom Nicole how are you you are
so sweet you always pay for me when I go
to see ariana shows yeah everyone it's
like no matter what I buy you still pay
for it and I hope that never changes and
I hope that stays consistent throughout
the entire time I know Ariana and her
family so thank you you tell your lovely
husband I don't like I said goodnight
and you give him a kiss on the cheek
alright there you go we're done Anna
wanna nope you're a wonderful sister